the electricity Supply to Miami has been
reduced adding to the suffering of
Nigerians Rabia can no longer support
her five children selling ice cream was
her only source of income
the freezer isn't working we only get
power for two hours we depend on this to
survive now with power outages even the
juices we have are undrinkable
most of niger's imports come from
neighboring Nigeria and Benin both
countries have imposed sanctions on
Niger which are affecting day-to-day
life
if we get the products at the old prices
I don't mind selling them at the regular
cost but if the wholesalers are selling
at a higher cost we will have to
increase our prices
since Western countries and
international organizations suspended
Aid the military Council has launched
several initiatives to reduce the impact
of sanctions
in the past we used to deposit our money
at the bank but now we don't go to Banks
anymore now we pay our taxes directly
these days if you put your money in the
bank there's no way to get it out
the closure of borders not only affects
the livelihoods of ordinary people on a
national scale the sanctions include the
suspension of commercial Financial
transactions preventing the military
Council from accessing niger's Assets in
both domestic and foreign Banks
opponents and supporters of the military
Council agree that sanctions are not
enough to force the Army to open the
doors of this Parliament restore the
Constitution and release president
Muhammad bazu
a
near me
foreign